I just want to share this stupid story
my dad was the one who recommended me
the books or was it my sister anyway my
dad and I were reading it at around the
same time okay and then that awful part
happens yeah yeah you know I'll see in
here and I read it and I was like so
disturbed and then my second thought was
[ __ ] my dad's read the same thing yes
very extra gross I saw the first movie
with my mom and sister two rows away
from the street I really wish I was with
the women in my family
[Laughter]
hi reject nation Greg Alba here what is
your name
patroller cut people would you know who
smote I I've had her to char here today
cuz we're gonna watch the trailer for
the girl in the spider's web the sequel
to Charlotte's Web the comedy train just
keeps on rolling up a reject nation
actually buy her because she has read
the books and I've seen the Swedish
movies and has seen the first American
film too
and speaking of Swedish stuff patron the
day shout-out for the one person from
Sweden who pledged to our patreon that
is Mikael linden Mikael is a guy who's
heavily encouraged me to go check out
Sweden if I'm not mistaken The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo must be his favorite
piece of cinema because it is Swedish
inspired do you love that Americans are
trying to captivate audiences by
remaking it in our English language
because that makes Swedish people happy
so we're happy to bring a smile to your
face yes Swedish son of a [ __ ] you know
it's not a franchise all right let's
check this out it's so cool they got
Rudy Marga returning David Fincher's
back yeah
you know Claire Foy right you met her
you knew her let's go yeah we went to
school together sorry it's the best
thing
[Music]
great relationship
Hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
she's the girl with the Dragon Tattoo
writer of wrongs
interesting
[Music]
the contact
yeah
what yeah I is it this but why is it I
just don't get stuck in the wrong
[Music]
November release dates have a pretty
good amount of confidence in this one
hmm it's better than December I think
the girl the Dragon Tattoo the first one
came out and like on Christmas
Oh which is why the movie underperformed
and it's been such a long time since
we've gotten another installment I've
only seen the girl the Dragon Tattoo
directed by David Fincher I know that is
Betty Alvarez who did films like don't
breathe in the remake of Evil Dead and
Claire Foy who's a Golden Globe winner
when I go into my opinions I just want
to say I really liked actually the first
girl the Dragon Tattoo
I thought Rooney Mara was amazing in
that film and Fincher's direction and
the cinematography was excellent this
was a bit of a readjustment for me till
I have to watch him like okay I'm gonna
have to really read on but what did you
think well obviously it's kind of weird
for me every time I watch something with
Claire Foy in it because I you know I
went to school with her yeah I know her
just as her but this is definitely very
different from things that she's done in
the past so she's done a lot of more
period stuff this sort of role I haven't
actually seen her in a part of me is
still kind of coming to grips with just
seeing her in this very different gritty
role and I'm not quite sure if I
completely buy her 100% in this just yet
she might be watching I know but what I
asked because I know her and her work
and her work ethic and how much she puts
into every single character I think that
she can pull it off she looks like she's
pulling it off it feels different than
the Rooney Mara performance which had
got an Oscar nomination so that's a
pretty heavy thing to follow up right
away I'm kind of confused on what the
approach is with this film
it's obviously not just a direct remake
of the first one this is one of the
sequel books so is this a sequel or is
it a soft reboot and they're just
starting with the girl in the spider's
web there's stuff about it that feels
like fede alvarez directed it cuz this
feels more like suspenseful kind of
horror action thriller and it seems to
lack a certain kind of mystery Menace
that Fincher can provide with his
projects which have this very like
serial killer mystery solving vibe and
this one seems to be like dead-ass chick
who saves women who are in harm by all
these old women who watch the shadow
gang-related
issues more of the antagonist problem so
it's interesting that they've kind of
gone with that Lisbeth Salander is this
bad that's badass heroine who gets his
reputation apparently the woman who
saves women in harm are you not the girl
who I would want fede alvarez to do his
own thing but there seem to be aspects
of the way it shot specifically that
look like it's trying to look like the
Fincher film i thought the scene they
essentially showed us I'm sure it's all
cut up for the trailer I like the way
that was all playing out and that was
pretty cool how it was being done the
cinematography does seem like it's
trying to look a little bit like a
Fincher film that's where I guess got
kind of confusing to me cuz I'm like
what are they trying to do specifically
with this film
the thing about fede alvarez though of
what i like about his movies he's not
afraid to go all out I mean the first
one has some violent moments in it and
there's some like brutal sexual assault
stuff that goes on in it but fede
alvarez can really amp that and I think
he would go much further out when it
comes to hard our stuff it's just right
now this feels more like some Sony
Pictures horror action thriller there's
something about seems to be lacking in
specialty to me although I am appealed
to it it just seems like they've kind of
like comic book characters are out is a
really interesting character because
she's extremely antisocial I think she
may be autistic like on this yeah deal
well with people that's why she's a
hacker well I know that's why Rooney
Morris performance really captures that
and here she just kind of seems like a
cool badass
yeah and I am also well aware that I've
saw the first one like three times I got
that really ingrained in my head and
this is like a completely different
approach I guess I gotta just see the
movie yeah honestly it still looks good
but all the hype about like we're
revamping it we're getting a new person
to star in it a new director will it be
worth it it's basically that it will it
be better this way will it work for more
audiences right now I can't really tell
if it'll do that I mean it looks good
I'll give it a chance November's are
confident time to release this movie no
matter what I'm definitely intrigued
this isn't something I'm gonna skip out
on all right guys well you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification because subscribe
buttons are kind of broken you could
check us out at patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage become a patreon check today
more importantly join a Charak hurt on
the get Jabby youtube get more get more
debbie in your life and Achara is like
an added bonus